any of you listening your first video is
not going to give views all you need to
do is make 100 videos and improve
something every time he knows how to do
this if you're nervous to get on camera
and you're fearful do it and do it a lot
and you will grow if you want to have
the biggest YouTube channel in the world
why do you want to do that it is very
interesting that he's saying the higher
he goes the lonelier he gets but I think
that if it's Lonely at the Top for you
you did it wrong
so this might be one of the most
tactical think media podcast episodes
for getting more views because we're
going to be talking about a recent
conversation with the fastest growing
YouTuber on YouTube breaking down all of
his Secrets Mr Beast and Lex Friedman
did a podcast super long it's like three
hours long but Nolan and I both watched
it and then there's an account on
Twitter Zach who really broke down some
takeaways and I was doing takeaways when
I was watching it Nola was making notes
of some things so we wanted to pull out
some quotes and really share those with
you so you can have some actionable
strategies for growing on YouTube right
now so Nolan I'm excited to get into it
yeah the first one uh basically these
are just some quotes from the podcast
from Mr Beast and the first one is don't
focus on metrics just focus on making
the best videos possible and then
metrics will be taken care of I mean I
agree with that I think that uh it's
kind of like what comes first the
chicken or the egg if you don't make
good videos the metrics won't be taken
care of and so that is a true sentiment
and I think it's an inspiring quote
because what can happen to people is
they can get overly stuck in the data
and the details not focusing enough on
making great videos and just focusing on
tags titles those little minute things
which are important but they definitely
come secondary and Mr Beast has embodied
this and it's working for him so I I see
this this is true one of the things that
he says so much and it kind of reminds
me of Jeff Bezos and how he always says
the same thing in all these interviews
and I believe what Jeff says I'm gonna
butcher this but it's something along
the lines of like whatever's best for
the customer and this is something this
quote I'm like I hear Mr B say this all
the time in almost every interview and
he's always talking about making the
best videos possible and there is you
know something about that and it's
clearly working for him and there's just
a lot to learn from how fast he's been
able to grow then next one is it's much
easier to get 10 million views on one
video than a hundred thousand views on a
hundred videos because if you make a
good video It's So Evergreen and it
never dies
so this is a powerful quote because
there's so much to learn and of course
Mr Beast has the receipts to prove that
this is true for him but I think out of
context I disagree with this meaning
this okay Mr Beast did a hundred videos
and even hundreds before he personally
cracked the code and built experience
two he had a little Mastermind with
other creators where they met every
single day for a year plus coming up
with what works on YouTube what doesn't
work studying YouTube and so he knows
the formula now he knows how to do this
and this is true for him because he'll
now put a million to three four million
dollars into one video and so he's
trying to say hey it's much easier to
make one great video spend a mill or two
on it you know what I mean not a not a
hundred grand like a million dollars on
a video so that is just so out of touch
with the regular Creator and I would say
that no actually it's not easier to get
10 million views on one video it's
easier to get a hundred thousand views
on 100 video for the average Creator
plus if you step outside of the niche
and you step into is that true for real
estate agents is that true for uh
service providers is that true and he's
not saying it that way he's definitely
speaking to that All-Star celebrity
entertaining YouTuber the one other
thing I would say is just comparing it
to one other example there's a channel
uh James Janney and he's been known for
making these kind of mini documentaries
that are 25 minutes to 45 minutes he's
made it about fake gurus he made one
about about mega churches he made one
recently about
cryptocurrency this thing is insane I
watched the entire cryptocurrency one
now we'll see how well it does they're
like Netflix documentaries they're very
well done they're very well done they
take him weeks upon weeks I think if not
months he he PO he posts pretty
infrequently because they're so such
masterpieces and some of them yes are
approaching that multi-million view
level maybe some are getting closer to
10 but on the flip side I think he did
one recently on scams yeah YouTuber
scams in the comments and it took a lot
of energy but it didn't even hit a
million
um so I think the punch line too is if
you're investing even on a smaller Mr B
schedule a ton of money a ton of time a
ton of energy and you're just saying oh
it's easier to get 10 million well a lot
of the people that are putting in high
levels of energy aren't consistently
pulling those types of views and I think
for for the average person it would be
much more practical to have more at-bats
if you're if you're just putting it's
like roulette you're putting all on you
know red not just red red 22 like that
is quite a bit of risk and if you
diversify your uploads I think what it
speaks to is how important quality is
but I think it set it at quite an
extreme and Mr Beast is such a unicorn
that I I agree with this one but I also
don't agree with it I completely agree
with everything you said and I just
think it's important for like people
listening to this podcast and I love
that we're having the conversation like
speaking to the average YouTuber because
most people don't have the understanding
of YouTube and when you're trying to
make these viral videos and you're
spending a lot of time uh if you miss
you miss big because you just spent a
month or two months on one video and
you're not Mr Beast and so you get 50
views that kind of sucks I I love this
conversation that we're having the next
quote was that the longer people watch
the more likely they are to keep
watching you don't need to try as hard
in the back half of the video as you do
in the front get people where they're
really immersed and hold them there yeah
I agree with this I love this because
um and we teach the perfect video recipe
which would be the big idea to hook the
content and the transition the hook is
just spending time to architect the
beginning of the video and if part of
that even if you were just to say do a
live stream and you were to do a video
podcast we thought about the hook up
front to try to pitch the value and say
why that you know listen to the end
there's going to be a lot of tactics
it's gonna be a very nuanced
conversation and so we are really
freestyling our responses based on our
experience here but we architected The
Hook Once people get to the back half
they're probably committed especially in
this setting you know there's people in
our think media podcast Community Watch
talking their dog right now they're at
the gym right now you don't really set
down the weights you're like committed
to listening to this longer form
conversation so this is completely true
I think that selling people not just on
the opening of the video but the topic
itself the topic title thumbnail that's
the big idea The Hook Once someone is
invested absolutely they'll probably
stick around so it's it's a poignant
sentence and a couple of sentences that
we could all learn from so Mr Beast is
hiring a big team of people to help him
because he has multiple channels and uh
I know you can relate to this and so I'm
interested to hear what you have to say
but the quote is that higher hard
workers who are really obsessed
coachable and train them on YouTube and
then a different quote that goes with
this hiring is people who see the value
in the work is who is who you should
hire so um not people using Mr B's to
get on TV and movies and I remember even
in the podcast or maybe it was a
different podcast he talks about how he
oftentimes doesn't hire people who are
applying that are in the Hollywood
industry because they don't understand
YouTube they don't have that same love
or understanding and I would love to
know your thoughts on this when it comes
to hiring and also how this can be just
applicable to solo creators looking to
expand and all the things with hiring
yeah this was one of my favorite parts
of the interview I think working
backwards the fact that he wants to
actually kind of avoid people that have
worked in traditional media and movies
because they also seem to disrespect
YouTube still which I think is an
underdog opportunity for everybody
listening to this YouTube is still
underrated it's still for he doesn't
want people that see YouTube as a
stepping stone he's like it's not a step
in the game it's the game itself and
it's actually the superior game recently
YouTube uh was talking about Creator
Trends YouTube blog and they announced
that the number one basically Ott
platform that Americans are watching
um or on their Smart TVs is YouTube that
their American families are gathering
around the TV and Nielsen reports
they're watching more YouTube than they
are Hulu and Netflix that's a big deal
and what's crazy Netflix is making
pretty cool original programming Hulu is
films are are cooler than ever movies
are better than ever but the math and
the data is telling us that YouTube is
the primary game so I think that's
fascinating in and of itself and and I
think I love that ethic because he's
building a culture as we're trying to do
at think media as well and you want
people that are aligned with your values
you want people that value as he's
saying the value in the work itself of
crafting YouTube content of being in the
crater economy of being in this new
media of this different type of media
than that media and no disrespect to
that media just like connect with the
world you want to be connected with if
you want to work your way up in
Hollywood then get on Set uh TV shows
and movies but if you want to be on
YouTube fall in love with YouTube so I
think that is a huge cult culture Point
as a leader you want to build a strong
culture you want to build a unified team
and I think that at the same time I
don't I wouldn't mind somebody that
wanted though to also even use think
media as a stepping stone I have no
audacity to think that like you'd have
to stay here forever or like YouTube
we'd only work with you know if you are
passionate and you want to hang with us
literally the way we met you're working
in Hollywood you're working on movie
sets and at the time too I was like for
sure bro and you had that dream and as
you spent time at think media I think
maybe your person I'd love to hear your
perspective has kind of shifted to see
you still love that world I think that
there'll probably be an intersection of
your passion for that world and what
happens in the future but you maybe
started to kind of feel differently
about YouTube over the years yeah I mean
so I moved to Los Angeles I got married
really young I was just about to turn 21
we got married two weeks later moved to
LA and I was going to presume pursue my
dreams uh filmmaking and that's that's
still something I want to do but I
definitely
um It's a Grind like it's it's a real
grind and I was a production assistant
you know and oftentimes driving an hour
hour and a half sometimes two hours in
traffic because of where we lived to
make it to the sets and it was always
different locations it was long days too
it was like 12 14 hour days and so it
was a it was a grind for sure right but
I also have always loved YouTube I've
kind of had these two passions of
filmmaking and YouTube and you and I
connected actually on my drive to La was
the first time I think you called me and
like you want to come and film we're
doing a conference and that was the
first growth video live
um and so you know we stayed connected I
came down filmed and we started doing I
started editing more for you guys and
started shooting some of the book tour
and and I had a really good time and it
I still love filmmaking but I kind of
came to a point where I was like now
dude I'm I definitely see the future of
YouTube and like I'm I'm so committed to
YouTube and so of course I'm not using
think media to like become an actor or
something or like you know like I could
see how that makes sense for Mr Beast
but for me I definitely saw the value of
YouTube and I was like I want to learn I
think that's you know we had another
podcast episode where we kind of talked
about this right and how people should
be working for YouTubers to learn and
build that education and so I feel lucky
to kind of get in when I got in to get
the experience and um yeah I I am on the
side though of like I'm with Mr I'm on
the side of Mr Beast I'm like I see
YouTube going far and uh and so I'm I'm
All bought in and that's one of my main
passions and so
it's been it's been a fun ride we've uh
We've Come quite a long ways and it kind
of even goes into the next one which is
managing creatives and Mr Beast talks
about this and this is something that uh
you know is is a new thing for me and
something that I'm learning uh my
current position is creative director
and this is a new role that I've stepped
into it think media and so though Kyle
on our team is the content team director
he does more of the managing creatives
but I mean I'm a creative at heart
Kyle's a creative at heart and we're
working with other creatives and I think
this part of the podcast is going to be
interesting for people who are looking
to hire that first editor that first
thumbnail artist because the quote is
the more constraints you put on the team
the more repetitive and less Innovation
you get after 10 videos people are gonna
say all right I've already seen this
what are your thoughts on putting
constraints on creatives that you're
bringing on to your team yeah I mean
this part also really stood out to me
and I actually agree and I think that
this is something I want to grow in and
you could transparently tell me your
feedback and my leadership style I
actually am kind of more the maybe
constraints guy because I'm a guy that
like loves a practical ranked videos
base hit video ranking Academy and I'm
like I'm not even trying to innovate
that much necessarily now of course
think media has evolved the brand has
changed I'm always trying to grow I
think you have to grow and change and uh
level up for each season but I am
self-aware that I think inside of a box
and I
um that's one reason why I have tried to
uh Empower you and Kyle to lead the
think media team and have freedom and so
and to not try to to have like yes we
have a framework yes we have certain
things and yes there's going to be
certain practical things we need to do
whether that's fulfill on a brand deal
or even practical things of ranking a
simple video it's such a different
mentality ability to rank a simple video
talking about tech and just make money
with affiliate marketing and make money
for the next five years with that video
is a different mentality than trying to
like break the internet Break YouTube
and crush the algorithm it's so so you
probably have learned about me I'm like
yeah I love that practical boring would
almost be the word like a little bit
more boring however I've acknowledged
and seen uh on you it's also one of the
reasons why I felt confident to even
literally make you the creative director
of think media that you are Innovative
you are creative and I wouldn't want you
to feel red tape or the inability to
experiment I tell you and Kyle like
there's all we're adhering to a five
upload schedule once you add shorts or a
goal is 14 think media podcast Longs and
shorts think media Longs and shorts and
lives combined in all 14 uploads
basically just daily on both I've said
also though like if you if we want to
slow down or let's take a week where we
invest that energy in one instead of
seven or different in things or let's
fill in the shorts and do longer I I
totally agree with this quote and I
think that the over structure or the
over managing or too much red tape kills
the creative spirit and what he
mentioned with some of his friends I
think he was talking about Eric or
different people who are trying to like
repeat the system down the line by
turning virality into a checklist and
that it is and it isn't though that it
can't be that there needs to be room
that if you just keep following a
formula it feels formulaic and now
you're no longer relevant I mean what do
you think yeah this is a I love talking
about this because I think a lot of
people on both ends can get constraints
confused with just like vision and uh
here's a great example so so I think
you've done a great job of giving us
not many constraints in a good way like
I feel like you have stuck to that
um I used to work at my church and I
don't know if you felt like this but my
dad was actually uh the pastor uh still
the pastor of the church and I was
working at the church in video and he's
not as creative as I am when it comes to
just video and and art and all kind of
stuff right and so he would we'd be
doing a video and he'd always cast a
vision for the video and I think for me
at the time I was also young but I was
like I would always combat him and be
like I think we should do this it was
like different you know I was like I
think I have a better idea I think I
think creatives just need to be more
open and communicate more because a lot
of the times you have someone who they
actually sometimes depending on who
you're working with they need to cast
some sort of vision so that we can just
get on the same page it really is just
communication so you might come to us
and say hey we uh we're doing a brand
deal with Canon uh the that maybe a
brand deal is not the best because we'd
be working with them but still the
communication of like you know the brand
or someone saying this is what we want
but as creatives like we're getting paid
for our creative thinking and so
communicating say what do you think
about this idea and not you know just
being
stubborn that someone's putting you in a
box it's like no just communicate and
and be open to uh giving them new ideas
and hearing that feedback and so I I I
was telling uh our we always tell our
team our content team
um and Kyle and I you know I think what
we try to do is create an environment of
open communication so we'll tell people
hey when we review your videos and we
make comments
creative is very it's it's opinion based
it's it's a gut feeling oftentimes with
a video it's like this feels slow paced
I feel like this shot should not be
there and so we tell our our editors uh
our thumbnail designers like please
challenge us if you think we're wrong
like let us know ultimately we still
have the final decision but we want that
open communication because in Creative
work it's like we know we we're not
always going to have the right answer
and I think it's just like being having
that humility to say together actually
we're that's why we do title crew where
we come up with 10 different titles for
a YouTube video and we all talk about it
together because collaboration I think
is the best way get everybody's
creativity and then let's decide on one
thing rather than saying I'm the boss
this is what it's going to be and so I
think um that has stemmed just from the
way that you've built the culture and
how we've been able to pass that down
I'm sure we could get better at that but
we try to leave that creativity open so
that people if you're creative and
you're not able to be creative that why
is that person in that job as a graphic
designer or as an editor might as well
work at a coffee shop yes and then in
their free time be creative you know
this is so good and we should I mean let
us know especially if you're watching
this on video if you'd want you know
more uh context or do you have any
follow-up questions I mean if you're on
audio hit up the video version and leave
a comment because I think we should do
some dedicated podcast episodes on
building creative teams or leadership
but the one other thing I've been trying
to grow in is and this is advice for
leaders that you should delegate
responsibility and not tasks when
someone's growing you may delegate tasks
but now you're going to be managing them
more you should delegate responsibility
so one of the things I tried to do is
try to simplify as much as possible and
one of the things I told you and Kyle
write was like if possible like you're
in charge grow think media 10 to 20 top
line and AD Revenue Affiliates brand
deals period and then I don't care how
you do it now I do care and we do have
feedback and whatnot and then of course
I want to be in communication there's
something you want to delegate but not
dump and there's something about holding
it's not just about numbers or profit or
something or gross revenue it's also of
course about culture and branding I
think it was grow at 20 while
maintaining trust with the community and
not selling out or violating our brand
and so to that end where I'm like
there's something disciplined about five
seven up five to seven uploads a week
however all the way back up to the Mr
Beast point I could see there being one
or two uploads a week and maybe we're
not getting 10 million views but instead
of getting 10 000 or 20 000 on each
upload we get a hundred thousand on two
uploads I know that I understand that
YouTube works that way so I don't want
you to feel that you're getting
micromanaged I think one way to kill a
creative spirit is to micromanage them
and I think the objection is sometimes
people if they're raising up younger
creatives they might feel like yeah but
they need so much management it's
attention to to be man managed to say we
met delegate Vision delegate a Target
and then actually Empower people to run
towards that Target because there's so
many different ways to get there I don't
care necessarily how you get there if
you don't violate the values or culture
let's experiment and to try to create an
r d experiment culture but yeah I hope
this conversation is valuable we could
keep it moving
um what's the next one yeah so Mr B
start talking about talking uh on camera
and this is cool because he wasn't he
wasn't the best at talking to the camera
and he's kind of evolved over the years
this quote was when I look at the camera
I don't see a camera I'm picturing what
the viewer sees when they watch it and
another quote to go with this is I can
perfectly picture what I'm filming by
looking at the camera and putting myself
through the lens of the camera while
making content I do it at the same time
he also said it's harder for him to talk
to a person than it is to a camera uh
what do you what do you think about that
it's a really interesting perspective
that he has when he's filming videos I
think the talk the takeaway here
especially for contextualizing for our
audience your camera cough if you're
nervous to get on camera and you're
fearful do it and do it a lot and you
will grow if you
um don't feel like you're a great
communicator do it and do it a lot study
the game tape study communication and
you will grow and I I caught when I was
listening to this interview that
repetition
has gotten him to a place where again
he's more comfortable talking to a
camera than a person he can visualize
that's everything is you don't know how
you look on camera but if you edit your
video or review your video enough and
you do it enough time you literally
begin to develop almost like a
four-dimensional perspective where you
understand where you're framed you're
understanding where lighting is you just
do this long enough and you're moving
things you kind of maybe even without
going and reviewing the footage you're
thinking about what the background is
and all these different details the
takeaway is start start messy and keep
doing it and these skills take time to
develop and then I think the other
takeaway there is in business they say
you should have a customer Avatar and
and YouTube you should have a target
audience and he says I'm picturing the
viewer when they watch it and
understanding the Creator who
understands the viewer best wins and I
know for some people especially in
business they a lot of times will name
their Avatar so they're like her name is
Susan she drives a minivan she has three
kids she's thinking about starting a
Etsy store so I'm always talking to
Susan she's 35 she's been married seven
years when you're creating content and
and obviously that's not the only person
watching your content but the greater
Clarity you have you know his names uh
Zach he's gen Z he's a gamer he uh likes
listening to Lil pump he likes less you
know he's
um wearing 90s fashion that's coming
back into style these are the other
creators he watched inches all of a
sudden Focus down your communication
style the same way you would is if you
were talking to someone's child if you
were talking to someone's grandparent if
you were talking to your own parent like
you're just you would communicate
differently when you get the that
Clarity and those handles on your
content creation that's when content can
really start to to resonate and Mr Beast
definitely knows whose audience he
understands this younger people Gamers
kind of mentality you know and he
articulates that a lot of gen Z people
and so even when some people are like I
don't love his content like some baby
boomers like I don't get what people
think is the big deal exactly he's his
content assignment for you and so who
are you making content for
um and the Creator who understands the
viewer best wins what do you think about
this no I think it's totally good I my
takeaway is I think the reason he's able
to look into the camera and envision
himself his body language the way he
sounds it's because he reviewed the tape
so much that now the that's that's kind
of what I've noticed is when I'm
shooting a video I'm like I'm doing what
in the last video I was like that was
annoying I need to stop doing that and
so for him he's watching his footage
back and I think people that's a
takeaway watch your footage back and
just kind of notice how can how can I
improve talking to the camera it's a
skill that can be learned and it does
take a lot of practice he I want to just
briefly touch on this one because I
think this will be super valuable for
people who have larger YouTube channels
or really want to scale their YouTube
channel and make it a legit business
like Mr Beast is doing but he talks
about how he has people in his company
that can think like him they make
decisions like me they'd make the same
decision I would make for four to five
years me and his CEO spent an absurd
time together and then he also said I'm
a big fan of finding people who are
super obsessed and all in and a players
that really just want to be great and
then just dumping everything I have into
them my question is how what are you
doing
um with with team members uh with with
even could go into hiring but the people
who are already on the team how are you
building them up to carry the culture to
carry the vision of think media so that
it can Outlast you you know when when
you decide to hang up the coat one day
yeah I mean this is such good leadership
content it really speaks to how good of
a leader Mr Beast is most people
probably maybe they would assume that
but you wouldn't really put them in that
category what he's building the team
he's building I think that uh one yeah
if people are gonna think like you you
need to process decisions together so
processing decisions together making
sure you're in communication the four to
five years thing is interesting we're
coming up on four to five years Kyle and
I are on like a decade Omar and I are on
like a decade Mel's like five years then
I think that should encourage listeners
that we have spent an absurd amount of
time together I think being in the
trenches together through growth video
live through challenges through even
spending this podcast today Mel's here
Kyle's here we're all hanging out we're
processing things in between a players
absolutely that want to be great a
commitment to Excellence having a
commitment in your culture to Excellence
I feel that way from top to bottom of
the think media team just because some
of our cultural values are lifelong
leaders or lifelong Learners we want to
level up we want to learn I would hope
so because that's also we want to
practice what we preach and we are
encouraging listeners to think media
podcasts the best investment you can
make is in yourself Eric Reese said the
only way to win is to learn faster than
anyone else so people that are obsessed
people that are growing people that want
to uh be great and then as far as
practically
um I am always looking to try to create
growth opportunities and Leadership
opportunities and so whether that's it's
convenient Kyle and I actually are our
parents all live in the same area in
Washington and so when he was up
building out that studio on that end we
were able to go out to eat and spend
time together you and I went to Miami to
film Patrick David so getting that time
together there's we're planning kind of
a Nashville trip and I'm asking you know
could we bring one somebody else on the
team with us who can you bring with us I
learned that back in youth ministry days
from Jeff Morris he said if you want to
develop leaders if you are going
someplace and doing it alone you're
doing it wrong now virtual teams is very
difficult but he would be like okay
um we're gonna do a little skate event
we used to do this a skate event called
8th Street we have to go to Home Depot
and pick up some wood for the ramps or
pick up some stuff for like the the
merch stand or the the food stand he's
like why are you going why aren't you
bringing somebody with you like like put
some just put somebody with you that's
really good and I think what people
think it has to be always structured
like let's sit down and talk about a
leadership book let's sit down and force
conversation actually just proximity
Morris caught then taught and I've I've
learned so much more just by being
around you being with you going to Miami
with you then you sitting down and being
like this is the way like no I just just
being around the right people I'm like
I've learned so much being being around
you and just the think media team I
completely agree with that and so that's
it I mean and I do think that uh for
someone listening to this I mean we also
are growing the team here at think media
you can always go to workwiththink.com
for open positions and then we're also
besides the open positions we are always
looking for people that are hungry and
obsessed and a players that want to be a
part of a cool team and a cool culture
and people can be remote here but I
remember the story of Jared glant going
to work for Grant Cardone he flew across
country got a cheap apartment lived on
an air mattress and this was like 13
years ago when Cardone Enterprises was
nowhere near what it is today like he
would even say if people even know that
name Grant Cardone like no one even knew
him like six years ago and now he's
blown up so there's like these tipping
points but Jared went 10 13 years ago if
possible moving to Vegas I mean at this
point you're in Eastern Washington
because of family and kids we're
spending more time so we definitely are
a remote team and then that'd be the
other thing is like I we don't have
offices right now so I'm always asking
how can we invest dollars also in team
and culture I do think Mr beaston his
friends and his team there's a lot of
they're very much in proximity because
they're creating so much physical videos
where there's their particular style
valuetainment requires everybody to
actually come to Fort Lauderdale and and
live there so it's different teams
different culture we definitely have the
remote opportunities but I do feel the
power on the Nugget of location even if
it's for a season can be very
life-changing changing your location
getting in the room getting there
physically getting around people I mean
even here in Vegas people that have come
out some you know people a lot of our
team is kind of has a faith background a
lot of people here go to the same church
Omar's got the video Department out here
different people who've helped us like
Donnie L is contract video editor she's
doing other stuff but they moved from
California and they got just in the flow
of things and it started leading to
Opportunities and leveling up and you're
kind of like so sometimes I don't know
maybe you're listening to this podcast
it might be smart to make a move it
might be smart to try to go change
locations and getting in the room so
that you can have an absurd amount of
time spent together we take everybody
out to eat you know on the think media
team yet last night that was here thanks
baby yeah I mean everybody's invited but
I mean if you don't live and people
understand that they got families they
got kids it's all cool there's something
powerful though about being there in
person and a lot of magic happens
especially in a virtual world like I
don't know why I'll land to play it on
this point here but it's like even still
we are going to we're in a season you
got Luca we've got Sean Bradley and John
Stephen kids and we definitely are
honoring that Family Value first but
we're also talking about how we're
hopping on a plane maybe once a month
all year long we're here part of the
year in Vegas to get in person and to
get into that Synergy and to get around
the other think team that's in Vegas and
whatnot I think that proximity can be
power especially in regards to cloning
yourself and hopefully not just cloning
Sean Cannell or cloning Nolan molt
because that'd be the next goal too I
always say like if you work yourself out
of the job I'll always give you another
one immediately from the day you start I
want people thinking about the
replacement not that you should ever
ever feel vulnerable or insecure that's
that's just what leadership is leaders
don't create more followers they create
more leaders and they are duplicating
themselves so the Legacy lives on even
if we don't go anywhere we're stronger
because we've cloned ourselves and so in
order to ultimately be able to do that I
think that spending an absurd amount of
time together getting in the room and uh
committing to whatever it takes you know
we're gonna be flying out a lot shooting
more of these in-person podcasts so
anyways love it
[Music]
this video is brought to you by stream
yard stream yard is our go-to platform
for streaming to YouTube and Facebook
with an incredibly easy to use interface
for built-in branding transitions text
lower thirds and seamlessly bringing on
guests it really is one of the best
options when it comes to live streaming
and what's so cool is they've
implemented a brand new feature called
local recording take control of your
audio and video with local recordings by
separating out your audio and video from
your guests this feature gives you the
control over your content for later use
making it perfect for podcasts and video
creators just go to streamwoodthink.com
to get started now
Mr B said the only way I found to
consistently come up with a hundred
million view videos is to take
inspiration and see what my brain
outputs I'd love your thoughts on uh
people I know a lot of people struggle
with plateauing they used to get views
they don't now uh what do you think
about this quote from Mr Beast yeah I
think that this is I've learned this as
well and here's my take if you're having
writer's block if you're having video
ideas block things that could be
powerful go for a walk take a nap
register for a conference go to a museum
watch some other YouTube content that
you normally wouldn't watch go to the
trending page listen to some music watch
a documentary about a musician on their
come up on their rise and how they
innovated their career you want to take
in inspiration and sometimes inspiration
from Divergent sources buy a concert
ticket go to a light show you know where
what's a light show I don't know go to
go to some kind of a cool art display
now it is interesting when you live in
inspirational places we you've been in
La that has a lot happening there go to
Disneyland go to California Adventure go
to you may not be doing anything at that
scale but sometimes just disconnecting
and plugging into something else read a
new book read a book you wouldn't
normally read grab a journal start you
know journaling at the beach go
someplace and there's so much
inspiration I think even in your
hometown we all get in ruts and routines
where you're taking the same roads
you're going to the same restaurants
you're going to the same coffee shop
like disrupt yourself and just get some
new inspiration kind of with no agenda
just in the simple fact of breaking up
the routine and then as he says see what
your brain outputs I have found that for
me I want to
consume inspirational sources of media
and experiences and I just need to get
out of my day-to-day and then and later
on quote unquote inspiration comes out
of your brain but you want to be feeding
it that different raw material so I
think this is a life hack it's a content
creator hack and I think that for those
listening to this
um you are what you eat so what is your
current diet of inspiration in Divergent
media sources experiences and it doesn't
have to be a one-to-one like I'm not
even that pumped on like art museums
although I love art and creativity and I
remember we went to the Palm Springs
Museum of Art or whatever it's like it
was a pretty cool experience but I
wasn't like I wasn't I didn't like look
at a piece of art and I was like there's
a YouTube video idea it's different
you're getting into different mediums
colors and then maybe you do take a
photo of a couple things and hang out
but simply the process of disconnecting
resting letting your brother tank up and
then I think a lot of times that helps
like you're talking about going on a
walk and stuff you might not have
inspiration for a new video going on
your walk but like that disconnect and
refilling that tank allows you to be
more creative is what I found yeah 100
so it's a very that's a powerful uh
quote on titles he said that the more
extreme the opinion typically the higher
the click-through rate if you can pay it
off in the content that supercharges it
yeah it's he's saying kind of Click bait
but ethical click bait because you pay
it off you can do it on the content and
yeah it's kind of the good and dark side
of of social media is that the
polarizing sides are what get the most
attention but I think you should use
this wisely and you should do it with
Integrity if you are truly convicted
it's about something then being bold
being Fearless not being afraid of fopo
other people's opinions fear of other
people's opinions it's just a fact and I
I was telling people the YouTube
challenge we did and we'll leave a link
in the description if you guys want to
sign up for the next one it's a it's a
free challenge and we were in the VIP
group and someone was asking about how
to engage in comments I feel like
there's a correlation here also with
titles because I agree with what he's
saying but I was telling them one of the
best ways to just flood the comments on
your YouTube videos is to make a strong
statement and that's kind of what he's
saying here with titles as well like if
you have an extreme opinion but like
you're saying you believe it like speak
on that like you you talk a lot about
Jesus you talk a lot about God your
faith and for some people that's very
extreme it's an extreme opinion to say
that the only way to the fathers through
Jesus that's an extreme opinion for a
lot of people but you believe it and
you're open about that and being open in
your titles being open about that in
your content and being authentic to who
you are I think of course it's gonna
you're gonna get comments you're gonna
get clicks because people are looking to
prove you wrong or they're looking to be
like I love that that's right and so can
you just speak a little bit about you
being so open with your faith you did a
podcast series on the Bible and that was
one of the most engaged with podcasts
and you're you're following exactly what
he's saying it's a and it's extreme
opinion but can you talk a little bit
about why why are you so open with your
faith I know you don't do it for the
views
um but can you just touch on where that
stems from and and why you do that yeah
I think it's been an evolution of
personal growth for me and I think a
couple things one the closer we get to
just being our authentic selves the
better and I think that that will also
resonate on content more like you as
soon as you're really you
your your true convictions your true
beliefs all start to get an alignment I
think there could be power there now
it's so guarantee that it actually will
get views or whatever but I just think
part of it for me was me just actually
overcoming fear and having a lot more to
do with it's just exactly who I am like
I believe that the Bible is the greatest
success book ever written I believe it's
a lot more than that but it's better
than any self-help any modern psychology
book in fact modern psychology is is
only now verifying things the Bible's
been saying for thousands of years and
so that's what I I feed off of I think
having good mentors too
um chalene Johnson encouraged me she
actually said you shouldn't really be
afraid of sharing your faith you should
be actually more bold about it for a
couple reasons one you should polarize
away people that are offended by who you
truly are because think about the
opposite I'm gonna pretend to be someone
else or I'm not going to be fully open
with My Views because then maybe I will
retain more of an audience well why
would you want to retain an audience
that doesn't love you for who you truly
are so it's like if you being open about
your true convictions pushes people away
that's a good thing and so of course I
think that I also try to be not weird in
the sense of we don't do like Christian
camera reviews it's not even such a
thing it's like other in certain
environments I think as I've had more
environments to also be more vocal where
if we're if we're bringing pure YouTube
tips well that's what it should be but
vertical video a podcast like this clips
from this podcast going out I think that
she encouraged me to again that that's
ultimately a good thing and then it
helps of course we respect Divergent
beliefs and opinions and all this
different stuff in our community but uh
those who come closest to us are people
and and Simon sinek start with why as I
studied that talk and that book he
talked about it's not just what you do
it's not just how you do it but people
it's why you do it and people like to
follow people with shared beliefs and
shared values so the more you talk about
your beliefs and values that's what will
polarize the strongest people to you and
then finally you were in Miami when pbd
was talking about in a 2023 and Beyond
world people just want to know where you
stand he's like the people that are
winning are actually the most vocal
about uh what they believe and that
these days even if people disagree with
you mature people can connect with and
be friends with people who don't believe
the same thing as them the people that
get offended by it actually show just
the lowest level of maturity
um because I want mature people can hear
from both sides kind of at least
entertain different opinions and then
still know what their own convictions
are so I think for example pbd is just
bullish on capitalism he's like that is
my mission what's very offensive to some
people but look at what he's built and
then look at people on the other side
whether you're on the writer left or in
the middle like I think what you're
you're seeing success in every single
vertical and so I have found that I'm
most fulfilled I'm most in alignment
integrity means being an inter integer
so it's not it at the deepest levels
it's not making something else up or
doing something for a gimmick like this
will be a good strategy it's actually
just as I've matured and the biggest
thing over to overcome is fear fear of
other people's opinions fear that what
if and I had to decide too am I more
convicted about my beliefs and my values
and more committed to those than I am
even about the success of our company
I'm not going to make our company
valuable but I don't care if I lose
followers that was that was at
previously I had fear what if I lose
followers what if I offend somebody and
one of the things I learned was forget
your faith or your religion you're going
to offend people no matter what you're
gonna offend someone for wearing a blue
jacket right now you're going so it's
just gonna happen you have to get over
the fear of other people's opinion the
fear of man is a trap it's a snare and
so you've got to get and that's such a
free place to be like I gotta admit I am
happier and more at peace and more they
I don't I wouldn't even say negative
comments have increased but every once
in a while someone you know will will
share something related to that but I'm
more at peace about it because again
it's not a gimmick it's just who I am
and uh I think that I think it's a
pretty cool and then it's until that end
it we also do teach that I mean look at
like someone like an Andrew Tate he is
the extrema the more extreme the opinion
and he has some of the most extreme
opinions people have different what I
can respect about him because I disagree
with I agree with a lot of his stuff and
disagree with a ton of it but I like
anybody who is not afraid to share their
opinion right like who is if he is being
authentic and he's being authentically
himself then good and that if you're
listening to this I think that's the
goal to do to get clear on your values
your convictions what what are your
extreme opinions those could also if
they're truly yours those could really
help you grow by sharing those on social
media and on YouTube totally agree uh
the next one is that Mr Beast is saying
that the next Mr Beast it's kind of like
the next biggest YouTuber isn't going to
do what I'm doing better they will
reinvent their own lane and it makes me
think of all the YouTubers out there
copying his style and I wonder if
they're missing it because what he's
saying is if you want to go farther than
me you need to be you times two yes no
that's what he's saying yeah you got to
be you times two I'm going to be mean
times three I I heard somebody uh that
were making like a meme about YouTube
gurus say that because I always say you
times two and uh you know what's funny
about that is I agree and I do Wonder
and not no shade against Mr Beast I
could turn it on ourselves
is his content getting tired is it
getting a little bit his his format is
ours I think that not only who's the
next Mr Beast gonna do what's the next
Mr Beast I'm confident he'll discover
that what's the next thing media like
this industry for sure you got to
reinvent yourself I think YouTube does
have a lot of correlative effect to like
the music industry and what you know in
the music industry is you always hear
about it you hear about one hit wonders
they have one Jam It's the Jam all
summer and they literally never come up
with another song and out through
licensing and through maybe that song
being used in movies that are thing it
could be good enough to to set get them
set up for life but the most interesting
artists are ones who generation after
generation continue to reinvent
themselves and stay relevant I people
could debate this so I maybe will
trigger some people but I think that and
I don't really follow her that closely
but I think Madonna has been one she's
been around and she's reinvented in
herself decade after decade I think
other artists the Rolling Stones I think
those guys are still performing right
now and they built a fan base and maybe
they've had not just multiple hit songs
but multiple hit albums you look at
somebody like a Kanye has consistently
you look at a Jay-Z over time
consistency over time that's built up a
catalog their sounds have also changed
their Styles have maybe and people the
joke with Kanye is you know we want the
old Kanye I hate the new Kanye you want
the old and nevertheless uh you can also
just look at the charts you look at the
numbers so no that's a good point I
think that number one the new Mr Beast
will do something different but also Mr
Beast will need to become the new Mr
Beast and I believe you will as is true
for us as as well and I think the
takeaway for The Listener you could
experience some short-term success
nothing wrong with it you could have a
great run maybe blow your business up a
little bit by leaning into YouTube get
some leads get some clients get some
sales if you're on that side of things
maybe launch your career and move it
somewhere else some people have done
that but if you want long-term success
in this you have to be committed to
constant Innovation and change and
reinvention I real quick want to get
your thoughts on Casey neistat yeah and
uh just to make this practical for
because I've seen a lot of big YouTubers
that were big five years ago that
are still doing the same exact thing
that worked for them back then and I'm
kind of under the belief that I think
Casey I think he's so talented and such
a good filmmaker and Storyteller that he
will make the shift but I'm watching
some of his recent videos and I just
noticed the view counts are so much
lower than when he was doing the daily
Vlog do you think someone like Casey who
kind of struck gold in this moment back
then like what does he need to do does
he need to reinvent himself because he's
such a big person like a lot of people
are like oh no dude he he's set but like
does someone like him what are your
thoughts on Casey neistat posting today
so with utmost respect for Casey and an
outsider's perspective
a couple things that I believe to be
true one I want to say I don't know how
well off financially I'll bring in this
piece of it how well Financial he was
because he did have an HBO series that
he sold before he ever
he worked with HBO did a whole series
with his brother the neistat brothers or
whatever before he even blew up on
YouTube two I'm not sure what is even
Financial background or his investing
background but it's not cheap to live in
New York with that big of a square
footage whatever so I'm speaking to the
aspect of financial stability and even
his vision for his life I don't know
what his vision for his life is so then
three not only did his YouTube channel
probably incredibly lucrative in a few
brand deals but then he creates beam and
sells it to CNN for 25 million and so I
don't know what he walks away with but
like depending on who you are kind of
like set for life money and that one
event that one exit event he also
himself said he burnt out from his
vlogging and they moved to to California
to live on the beach and and kind of
rest and recover and Surf and now he
seems to be in kind of the same mode
PewDiePie is another good example
PewDiePie is self-articulated that he's
retired he's like I'm done I actually
have retired and he shows up every once
in a while he'll pop on and do a book
review or like react play because he
wants to and so is he retired it's like
you know different hip-hop artists like
announce the retirement just so they can
relaunch an album a couple times and
maybe it's not that they weren't sincere
about retiring Tom Brady like that you
retire and you come back like it's your
choice to come come out of retirement so
I think that
my conclusion and a long answer to the
Casey neistat question is one I kind of
think he doesn't care two he's making a
documentary it's I think it's done about
David dobrik okay yeah so I think you
all because he's solved the money
problem and maybe it's been solved he's
able to just follow his creative
passions and I would say and would be
also true about Mr Beast you're driven
by the work and the creativity but not
everybody wants to that would be the
assumption that YouTube and like going
viral on YouTube and Reinventing
yourself on YouTube is what winning
looks like and that that is your
definition of success that's fine but I
don't I would it would appear that
Casey's energy towards his channel is
kind of like he doesn't care that much I
mean he loves his audience he loves
creativity but he's kind of doing what
he wants when he wants the upload
frequency so he's not pushing to just
crack the algorithm whereas Mr Beast it
would seem as trying to better his
previous best constantly win the YouTube
game I don't think he wants to make a
documentary or something else that is
what he wants to do and so it's a very
good conversation that you bring up
because
um in some cases people need YouTube to
work so they should be incredibly
focused as your point they should be
figuring out the next version of
themselves or figuring out how to keep
winning on YouTube because they have not
solved the forever financial problem
like someone like Casey and I know
that's not the only piece that comes
into it but yeah it would seem to me
that that's he wants to do other
creative projects fun creative projects
have fun do what he wants when he wants
collab with different friends and what a
cool point if you're disciplined on
YouTube for a while or you go on a run
on YouTube for a while that could be the
vehicle that allows you to eventually
kind of just follow your creative Muse
wherever it leads you I think that's
where Casey neistat is right now Mr B
said that all you have to do is make a
hundred videos and improve something
every time that's all that's all you got
to do Sean yeah I don't know if it's all
you have to do and he said that a lot
but I think I think that's I think
that's true that's a great principle
it's a great number to Sprint for
because so few will ever reach there and
it's not like upload the 100 of the
lowest quality shorts so you can say you
check the box but if you really sit down
and plan out a title
a topic and a thumbnail and a concept
and put some energy into a video and do
it a hundred times you will just
transform as a human and if you get a
little bit better each time even if you
walked away from YouTube after that you
will be different that is a that would
be I think everybody on planet Earth
should upload a hundred videos and try
to improve something every time I'm not
guaranteeing you'll be a successful
YouTuber I am guaranteeing you will be a
better person you will have learned
things learn things about yourself
overcome phobias overcome fears you will
be transformed you'll be more valuable
to the marketplace you'll be more
valuable to the uh your family and you
will also have greater self-awareness
even if you made the videos private
after I think that that is an exercise
just like going on an 100-day discipline
of working out or 100 day of changing up
your diet if you upload 100 every single
human should upload 100 videos on
YouTube just for how it will change
their life for the better the key here
is he's saying volume will
its volume and analyzing and uh Alex
hermosi has a great quote that is volume
is the answer and time is the ingredient
and so many people don't do either of
those things they want to grow on you
YouTube but they don't put in the volume
and then they don't give it time and so
I love that Mr beaston shares uh about
his path to a hundred billion dollars
and he said that my goal is to make the
best videos possible I know whatever
else that I want will come from that so
the path to 100 billion is to keep
getting a hundred million views of video
or more wow I mean I believe he will
I believe Mr Beast will reach a hundred
billion dollars in terms of the
valuation of his companies and I think
it is cool that he's found is one thing
make great videos because out of that he
has launched Mr Beast burger and
feastables and he's launching these
other projects but what's fascinating is
the reason he's able to do that is he
has said he's hiring the best people
he's hiring CEOs from other packaged
Goods Brands to run his chocolate bar
and it's his commitment to focusing on
his strengths doing the thing he's best
at that is the path to the expansion of
the Empire I think a lot of us could
learn from that that um maybe focusing
on getting to your first ten thousand
dollars on YouTube You're a hundred
thousand dollar a year a seven figure
business an eight-figure business is
figuring out a core product and this is
true for any business what is your core
offer what is your core product Mr
BEAST's core offer and core product are
these incredible videos sure gaming
reaction Channel also does good sure
little side projects does good but
what's the one thing and he's figured
out his one thing and he wants to keep
going deeper on the one thing as the
path to expanding into multiple things
through the help of Team systems and
building a brand so valuable that it
kicks open every door I love that and
the this next one goes really deep
uh so just kind of prep yourself for
this because he started talking about
how every Milestone that Mr Beast would
hit at one million at 20 million and now
he's 100 million and even over 130 you
know maybe 150 by the time people are
watching this uh podcast he talks how he
got he gets more and more lonely and he
means that there's less people there but
it's really interesting because you have
someone who is breaking records and is
using the word loneliness when you think
they would attract more friends more
high-level people around them bigger
more money he's becoming more lonely I
don't know what is
what advice would you give to people who
feel lonely in in their content creation
and are maybe chasing success and the
further they get along they feel like
they're not and I don't want to say this
that is Mr Beast maybe it's slightly out
of context but I think it's a really
good conversation because we've just
seen it so many times where you reach
new levels but you get more lonely I
don't know if that's something that
you've encountered but what would you
say to that well this actually gets me
kind of passionate and again with
respect for Mr Beast another quote he
says here there's just not that many
people that want to give up everything
go all in and then obsess over making
the best videos every day of their lives
I mean I think it's I think it's a
little unhealthy honestly I think that
one I respect what he's doing two he can
make his own choices three he's found
his obsessions he said it's this or I'm
dead but you know I come from a Biblical
worldview with the belief that things
like family and things like people
people should have children if they can
they should get married and he may do
all those things he's young I think he's
24. they should have I think they should
have balance I'm not trying to judge
somebody that goes to an extreme but
there's a verse in the Book of
Ecclesiastes that says the man who fears
God avoids all extremes mind you this is
written by somebody who was a lot bigger
than Mr Beast in the context of his ERA
King Solomon is the wealthiest man who
ever lived still by if you go by
inflation and the value of the gold and
all the data that is recorded in the
Bible is the wealthiest man who ever
lived he had Vineyards and he built
cities and he built all these different
things so he had a big life just like
this and he got to this place of things
are vanity things are meaningless I
think that Obsession out of control will
lead you to a bad place I think and the
path he's on the amount of Fame and
accolades and money and open doors and
opportunity
that's enough to mess up anybody's Soul
just that's enough to await to carry
pressure to Steward and so I'm one
really grateful that he is being uh
vulnerable about this two
um it is very interesting that he's
saying the higher he goes the lonelier
he gets but it's my belief other people
do say that it's Lonely at the Top but I
think that if it's Lonely at the Top for
you you did it wrong you did not nurture
relationships along the way that weren't
just about business
you did not
leave maybe some money on the table or
some opportunity on the table again
treading lightly I don't want to be
critical but this whole thing he'll push
himself to burnout rest a couple days
and get back to work you see a little
bit of Elon in there as well and I'm not
sure how elon's doing but but what my
conviction in seeing that this book the
Bible who really can read the human
spirit and soul and is just prescribed a
way of life that doesn't just lead to
success but leads to Total success like
the Hebrew concept of being blessed is
soul Prosperity happy in your heart
happy in your mind happy when you're
alone having
peace like a river Joy like a fountain
like having these these are the things
that matter most in life and at think
media we don't throw the baby out with
the bath water we're like yeah let's
build big companies and let's generate
wealth and let's make a difference and
let's hustle really hard and let's be
obsessed but I I get to experience a lot
of different entrepreneurs that you know
Jesus summed up the whole thing he just
said what good is it to gain the world
but lose your soul
and I don't know I don't hear people
talking about those things I have never
heard Mr Beast and you may have said it
somewhere
Express
an interest in guarding his soul or his
mental health or some of those things so
from an outside loving perspective it
would just be that I think the
intentionality to invest as much energy
that you invest in making great videos
into family or friendships or or your
own soul and of course at the deepest
levels that that a life that ultimately
is disconnected from the Creator and I'm
not sure where he's at but this just
goes for anybody a life that's just not
connected to the Creator will never
fully find that for fulfillment so yes
you will reach the top at the end of the
book of Ecclesiastes what Solomon says
is he goes I actually kind of learned
the conclusion he went down a really
dark path and he went down the path of
like partying and going super hardcore
into Vice he also went down the path of
going super hardcore into being proper
and disciplined and he's like on either
side if I'm not connected to my Creator
it's vanity it's meaningless and at the
end he said man fear God and obey his
commandment so I do think there's
something about staying grounded and
it's interesting to watch this as a a
case study playing out this and
everybody else like everybody we're
seeing what YouTube is doing we're
seeing what rapid Fame can do I would
even call it rapid he has put in the
work it you could argue it's been slow
growth like in the sense of we're
talking years it's not like this is
overnight for Mr Beast there was years
of obscurity a couple hundred videos
before people knew him he definitely has
been put in the work growing into this
whole thing but this is a a real
interesting thing to consider I think um
that we should be thoughtful of about we
don't want to be rushing so hard to get
to the top of the mountain that way it's
Lonely at the Top If it's Lonely at the
Top you did it wrong I just think
everyone including myself you know I
don't want to and I know you're not
being critical and I want to be critical
of Mr Beast I think what we can do is
just like if Mr Beast was he's probably
not going to listen to this but if he
was I would want to like just ask him
why and that's a question I'm asking
myself you know just to put it on myself
I'm like anyone anyone watching this if
you want to have the biggest YouTube
channel in the world if you want to make
the most money in the world if you want
and fill in the blank it's just like why
do you want to do that and I think for
me you know that's just something I've
been looking at the goals that I've been
setting and I'm like why am I really
really chasing after this goal because
when I get there well that actually
satisfy the thing that I'm longing for
and ultimately you know I'm a Christ
follower as well you know and I grew up
in church my parents are pastors and
past few years you know I I've
definitely disconnected just from like
that time with God but I found uh just
these past couple months I've just kind
of been spending more time with him and
I and I feel that purpose like kind of
come back where it's it's been a shift
and I and I think people need to to
think about why and it's a really hard
question to grasp
um and so because I just know at the end
of the day if I make the amount of money
or the amount of subscribers if I get
that silver play button
is that actually going to be it for me
or will be on to the next thing and and
I and I just know me and I know that
some of those goals that I've been
chasing aren't going to Satisfy My Soul
and um you know for me I've I've found
that in in God and and I think that's
why you know I connect and a lot of
people connect with you too you're open
about that uh and finding that
connection there and it's a deep topic I
said this one was gonna get deep because
it's like back to YouTube why are you
doing this in the first place and I love
that you talk about your why and you
teach on that and you and you tell
people to like focus on that and the
mission and and uh it's not all about
views it's not all about subscribers
like we're doing something deeper here
and
um it's a heavy convo we that we're
gonna need to probably dive into another
podcast about it because
yeah it's deep yeah no I love this combo
and it kind of reminds me like
at some point
it's a good exercise to
write your Epitaph is that what it's
called you write your eulogy one of the
things I read a book 10 15 years ago
that said write your own eulogy what
they would read about you at your
funeral
because you want to talk about ultimate
reverse engineering work backwards from
that day you're dead and the even the
process of writing your own eulogy would
be to sit down and and so for me I might
want to say like he was a man who was
generous he cared about his family he
was a man who cared about other people
you also hope you're writing down maybe
some ideals and then you're thinking man
I'm going pretty fast right now like I'm
I'm burning I'm blowing past people I'm
so much more obsessed with success am I
really valueing my relationships one of
the things that I need to constantly
readjust is is uh my is is friendships
the category of friendships and I know
that men stereotypically sometimes are
like you go like a year and then text
them and it's like you just I just text
my friend Jesse Tillman from high school
uh I just text him back and I was
actually sitting with my friend Spencer
Hurst in Washington and I'm so in well
I'm also in the season of the kids so
it's like it's like think Media Kids
Sonia and that's it but I'm sitting
Spencer comes over and I'm like we're
talking about Jesse so I bring up my
phone with Jesse and I I thumbs up his
last text to me and I text him back it
wasn't quite two years since I replied
to his text I ghosted him for two years
now he knows me and and he was then he's
selfing me back we're talking back and
forth he's with his uh wife Emily and
just love them so much I think we've
maybe hung out with them because he
comes he runs a concrete business he
comes to Vegas for this concrete
conference here's the point it's an area
where when you when you think about the
end you work backwards
you have to make adjustments along the
way when NASA or SpaceX launch a
launches a rocket it's not going to hit
Target the Target unless they make
adjustments along the way it's why you
need a dashboard it's why you need to be
constantly making adjustments the
opportunity to hear from Mr Beast and
all of us is to identify something like
I just get more lonely as I'm going to
the top and and that's like a check
engine light that is like it it doesn't
even have to be overly dramatic
necessarily what it should be though is
we probably need to make some
adjustments and look at how cool it is
that you blast off you you took off
you've made a ton of progress you're on
your way to the destination but if you
don't check in with your soul and with
the other gauges you want to make sure
you're measuring the right things if all
were measuring like you said why why is
the success the videos that's a great
success he's a inspiration to a lot of
people but what about the other areas
and I think a life that is bankrupt in
some of the most important areas and for
me we all probably have our extremes we
over index on maybe even the family side
where like family is everything and
that's a cool thing but like for a lot
of us not everyone's may be called to it
but like building something and building
a channel and building a business and
building something you're proud of is
another piece of the puzzle it's just
not the only piece and So lately I've
been thinking a lot about if a pilot
leaves Florida to fly to Seattle they
have they have a dashboard and they have
instruments that they tweak the flight
path along the way if you are not
checking in with your flight path you
will be way off course and and that's
not anywhere any of us want to be taking
some time checking in with our soul our
health our mind where are we at our
relationships and taking an honest gauge
of if you've been investing I know he
even his girlfriend which is cut he's
like we like to learn together because
if it's not about learning then it
doesn't matter it has to all map back to
the channel that's the season he's in
that's totally cool but I think that a
little bit more margin I think for most
people especially most type type A
driven entrepreneurs type of people
people wired like us I think that their
propensity
is to go too extreme and to neglect
areas that that matter and I think that
at the end of our Lives we won't be if
we left a little bit of money on the
table or we left a few thousand
subscribers on the table or we left a
few projects on the table I don't think
that those will be the things that we
will uh be as worried about I think we
might wonder dude I can't believe I
never text Jesse back man you know what
I mean like I can't believe I I didn't
check in with Jesse and Emily for such a
long time people matter most
relationships matter most our
relationship with God matters most the
community we're in and it's not either
or it's both and but I know I'm given to
that extreme so one I think caring about
Mr Beast I agree like nothing but love
two this is an opportunity for us here
on the think media podcast to even have
a personal check-in with where are we
going what are we building and how can
we make adjustment not even to get super
like mad at ourselves it wasn't you know
Jesse's laughing about it that's the way
the nature of our friendship he's like I
literally can't believe it took you one
year and nine and a half months to
respond to my last text message he's
like bro I asked if you want to go to
coffee uh he goes they shut down
the whole landscape of the town has
changed since then a good reminder to
just man what are we building where are
we going why are we doing this and hey
think media podcast let me know what you
got out of that episode and if you
actually want to check out the episode
Nolan mentioned all about three YouTube
Secrets I learned from the Bible that
every Creator should know click or tap
the screen to check that out subscribe
if you're not subscribed hit like and
we'll see you in the next one